alright thanks for thanks for being here
thanks for tuning in by the way my wife
keeps telling me that my bookcase that
you see behind me looks cluttered and
ugly on video and I need to stage it
properly but you know I tried to explain
that my I am a cluttered and ugly person
so it just it kind of fits the overall
theme that I'm going for plus I think
that book cases should be cluttered and
chaotic they should look like that just
a total disaster zone because bookcases
that are too organized then well then
you know that they're just there for
show it means that nobody's actually
pulled a book off the shelf and read it
so that's a bookshelf that you know is
used we actually have though a
decorative bookshelf in our house I'm
ashamed to admit now I didn't choose
this as my wife made this choice but
it's it's not my fault but my wife
staged a bookshelf downstairs with like
these antique books that she went out
and she bought antique books out of some
way I don't know where you buy and and
they're just decorative books like we
don't you don't read them we're not
supposed to read them they're just there
on the shelf to look at and so you can
say oh those are pretty books they're
real books I mean you could read them
there are words inside the book but you
don't read them it's just it's all
decorative so but this is not this
bookshelf is functional it serves a
purpose and so I feel like it's it's you
know in that sense it's quite it's quite
beautiful alright so a lot to talk about
today or I could just talk about my
bookshelf for another 30 minutes the
let's talk first about socialism the the
socialist country of Venezuela is if
you've been watching the news is falling
apart before our eyes it was once the
wealthiest country in South America and
now after not all that long ago either
but after a couple decades of socialism
it is a failed state now and it's
disturbing then when you see what's
going on to Venezuela it's disturbing to
think about how many people in my
generation and the generation after ours
want to adopt that system in our country
the system that led directly to the
chaos that we're seeing in Venezuela
they want that in our country
polls show that almost half of when you
combine the millennial and I guess it's
generation Z they're the ones after us
how did that happen by the way we got of
Generation X and then Millennials and
then we went right to Generation Z how
do we skip a letter I don't understand
that but if you combine is in and when
they've been pulled we find that 50% of
the combined forces there want socialism
in this country and of course they're
being herded in that direction by the
avowed prominent socialists in the
Democratic Party like Bernie Sanders and
Alexandra okay zero Cortese so following
demographic trends you know it's not
inconceivable that in twenty thirty
maybe forty years we could have our own
Venezuela moment in this country but you
know if you're still a little bit on the
fence about it and and and you can't
decide whether or not you are in favor
of socialism I think there's a very
simple test that should clarify things
for you okay and I know I'm not the
first person to make this point I won't
be the last person either it's an
obvious point it's obvious because it's
unassailable and people bring it up all
the time because it is it's just it's
just true and the point is this you
would never want to live in a socialist
country now you might say I want
socialism in this country yet it's
interesting to note that although you
want socialism in this country you
wouldn't actually want to ever live in
any of the countries that are socialist
right now shouldn't that tell you
something take a look at all the
socialist countries in the world today I
mean think about any any socialist
country and there are several of them
would you want to live in any of those
places because you could I mean you
could get you could get on a plane and
go to any of those places
if socialism is a good idea if it's even
a a path to utopia which is how occasio
Cortez presents it then there should be
in existence today a number of socialist
countries that you a socialist might
consider moving to so which one would it
be Venezuela North Korea
China Tanzania Sri Lanka Nicaragua which
of those would you want to move to of
course the socialist sympathizer in
America will when you talk about
socialist countries the first thing
they'll say is well what about Sweden
what about Denmark and they'll say that
those are socialist successes the
problem with calling you know the
Denmark or Sweden the Nordic countries
socialist successes is that they aren't
socialist so it's hard for them to be a
socialist success when they aren't
socialist in fact the prime minister of
Denmark addressed this question in a
speech I think at an American College a
few years ago here's what he said he
said I know that some people in the u.s.
associate the the Nordic model with some
sort of socialism therefore I would like
to make one thing clear Denmark is far
from a socialist planned economy Denmark
is a market economy okay so you heard it
from the horse's mouth the guy who runs
done now Denmark it's not it's not it's
not socialism so if you want to live in
a socialist country it seems that a
cottage in Copenhagen is out of the
question so where else are you going to
go the closest you know the if you want
to talk about a real socialist success
story what do you I mean the closest
thing you might have is like Bolivia or
something which isn't really a social
success story either but at any rate
would you want to live in Bolivia would
you prefer Bolivia to here now we could
expand this hypothetical search to
include historical places let's say that
so I'll give you all as many options as
possible let's say that in this
hypothetical you could take either a
plane to your destination or a time
machine and you could go to any
socialist country that exists or has
existed which state-controlled
Wonderland would you choose to go to in
the past
Soviet Russia Nazi Germany which was
socialist Cambodia I mean where are you
going
socialism and communism killed a hundred
million people in the 20th century and
Counting so if you do decide to go on to
those places I would say you know just
be be very very careful when you get
there so we can you know we could sit
here and talk about the economic and
philosophical problems inherent to the
socialist model we could you know we
could do that all day but it to me it
seems like the proof is in the pudding
it seems like this is this is really it
right and this is a pudding that is made
with misery and starvation and tyranny
and death on a scale previously unknown
to mankind and that is not a good
pudding that's not how that's not how
that's not the recipe I use for my
pudding I'll put up I could tell you
that so maybe we should just take the
hint one or two examples of socialism
failing would not be enough to discredit
the entire system I admit that but we
have now over a century of chaos
bloodshed and poverty directly brought
on by this system of governance and I
think that that's a pretty good sample
size I mean we have dozens of countries
who've tried it over the last 100 years
and not only has it not worked for them
but but very often it has resulted in in
genocide and mass starvation so it's
just maybe take the hint is what I'm
saying and so all that's left for the
socialist proponent in America is to say
that well that none of that is real
socialism it's it's not it's not the
real all of that none of that is real
the real socialism isn't that well you
know if if dozens of countries have had
it over the course of 100 120 years and
all these countries have tried it and
none of them could do it right according
to you maybe that means that it seems
like there are two possible explanations
either you're wrong about what you
consider to be real socialism and those
are real examples of socialism which
is the correct answer by the way or
best-case scenario if you're looking to
defend social as well that's not real
socials well then that means that
socialism is just something that doesn't
work in in in the real world that can't
be brought to fruition it's an idea it's
a philosophy it's a it's a utopian dream
you know best-case scenario for you
that's what it is so that's the that's
the best you could do but actually
that's it's not even that you know
because I know that there are people who
say well communism and socialism great
ideas but when you when you try to put
them into practice that's when it all
goes to goes to hell well yeah they're
not great ideas because if it's a great
idea
but every time you try to put it into
practice it kills tens of millions of
people then you know that probably means
it's not actually a great idea and
socialism communism these are not great
ideas because they are ideas that
they're core are antithetical to to
Liberty to freedom and thus to human
flourishing and that's why it always
works out the way it does yeah look
Venezuela
you know Soviet Russia all these big
North Korea
that's real socialism that's what
socialism is and that's what happens
with socialism I was talking about this
yesterday on Twitter someone someone and
you get this response all the time
someone emailed me and said said oh you
don't like socialism how well so I guess
you don't like when that when the when
the government builds roads no you see
that the government building a road is
not socialism that's not a socialist Act
it's not like the only other alternative
to socialism is for the government to do
nothing I'm not saying the government
should do nothing I'm saying that the
government shouldn't control everything
which is what happens under socialism
yes there are certain things in a free
country
there are certain prescribed roles that
the government takes on and it does not
go beyond those roles
ideally one of those is sometimes to
build roads but that is not socialism
all right um so we've discussed before
on the show moving on here another topic
we've discussed on the show what happens
when pro-abortion people speaking of
horrible ideas the pro-abortion position
you know what happens when pro-abortion
people are accidentally and momentarily
honest about what they believe you know
the pro-abortion position usually comes
to us cloaked in euphemism cloaked in
codewords propaganda dishonesty a few
skatin misleading talking points in
rhetoric that's usually the way it goes
but every once in a while someone from
that camp will take off the mask and let
their true faces show and it is a
hideous face indeed that actually
happened twice this week so let's take a
look at both examples both caught on
tape so first we've got Alabama State
Representative John Rogers he is railing
against a wonderful bill in al Alabama
that would criminalize almost all
abortion which is which is just just
awesome
but John Rogers doesn't like that very
much and this is the case that he makes
against restricting abortion Oh a
woman's choice I'm not about to be a
male till a woman was doing her body she
has a right to make a season itself
directly instead some kids and unwanted
so you kill him now I kill him later
you break them in the world on one I
love these sends a negative so you kill
them now I kill elated
but the bottom line is that I think we
should me make this you see all right
you can kill them now or you can kill
them later there are those as quote
right so there are a few interesting
things happening in this clip the first
is that a rambling unintelligible
psychopath was apparently elected to
office as a Democrat in Alabama in fact
I looked this up he's been reelected
many times he's been an off and since
office since 1982 so 37 years for a man
whose argument for abortion is we got to
kill kids now or kill him later so what
does that tell you about the Democrat
Party also what does that tell you about
how easy it is to be a politician that
you can have an IQ of 12 and be a
bloodthirsty psychopath and and and
still get along swimmingly in your
career as a politician for 37 years the
second interesting thing is that Rodgers
admits that these are kids he admits
that it's killing and of course those
facts are completely self-evident and
unavoidable so you don't get credit for
admitting them but most Pro Boortz will
not admit that yet he does and you know
it's kind of like socialism that like I
said what does it tell you about
socialism but whenever you get a good
look at it it's horrific well it's the
same thing with with the pro-abortion
position what does it tell you that
anytime a pro bortion person is just
Frank and direct and honest and doesn't
try to get around it's a it's not really
a baby it's a fetus it's a clump of
cells you know it doesn't use any of
that just says yep here's what it is
here's my defense of it what does it
tell you that anytime someone does that
the results are nightmarish and
bone-chilling speaking of bone-chilling
and there was another random act of
honesty by probe orts this week also
caught on video this is from the
University of Texas San Antonio actually
the incident I guess happened sometime
in April but it just went viral this
week
pro-life students on campus had set up a
display called cemetery of the innocence
which is a display looks like a cemetery
which is meant to remember and
memorialize the innocence who are killed
by abortion some feminists got wind of
this and here's what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
okay it looks like we have an officer a
couple of officers on site all right
well as I as I watched that again I
guess I should I should have mend the
way that I set that video up I said that
it's honesty but it's not it's honesty
in that it reveals the dark and depraved
heart of pro-abortion advocacy so it is
honesty in that sense but these women
who are acting proud of their abortions
these women acting so flippant about it
joking about it they are they are not
being honest with themselves or with us
not at all you know what you're watching
here what you what you saw there were
broken human beings trying to convince
themselves not convinced us trying to
convince themselves of what they're
saying trying desperately to stave off
the guilt and self-loathing that they
feel by pretend by way overcompensating
that's what's going on there
you know probe orts like to pretend that
getting an abortion is basically you
know just like getting a getting a
filling at the dentist or something but
a normal procedure no big deal nothing
to freak out about that's what they say
well it's weird because if there were
some whack jobs out on a street corner
screaming that it's immoral and evil to
get a dental procedure would you buy
they're going up to them with a sign and
screaming I got a dental procedure and
I'm proud of it I got a feeling I'm
proud no you wouldn't you would roll
your eyes at these people and say these
people are crazy and and and you would
go about your day you're not gonna
you're gonna argue with them because you
know there's nothing wrong with getting
a filling at the dentist there you know
there's nothing wrong with getting your
cavity taken care of you know that you
don't need to argue with someone about
it you don't need to defend it
you're you'd have no interest in doing
that but with abortion what you find is
that these women feel the need
Wow while claiming that the pro-life
position is crazy and it's just as
delusional as somebody railing against
getting a cavity filled while they say
that but yet they take the time and they
feel the need to grab the sign and march
around saying I am so proud well here's
the thing pretty much 100% of the time
when someone is making a point of
declaring how proud they are of
themselves of something that they did it
means they aren't proud it means
whatever it means is they want you to be
proud of them but they want you to be
proud of them because they're not proud
of themselves you know they they they're
they are not confident you know being
being being prepped pride is confidence
and a confident person doesn't go around
shouting whoa look what I did isn't this
great everyone looked say you see how
great this is this thing that I did
confident people don't do that because a
confident person they don't need other
people's approval and if you know that
you did the right thing you don't need
other people to know about it you don't
need to convince them of it you just
know that it was right so that's what's
going on here these are pitiful figures
pitiful sad desperate guilt ridden
people and let's not be fooled by the by
the charade by the game they're playing
because
it's not very convincing all right
finally before emails this is a report
from The Daily wire says kirsten
gillibrand told NBC news that her first
major camp campaign plan would be called
the clean elections plan and it would
get give every voter $600 she called it
democracy dollars to donate to the
federal candidates of their choice she
explains ok under the plan every
eligible voter would register for
vouchers to donate up 200 $100 in a
primary election and $100 in a general
election each cycle either all at once
or in $10 increments each participant
would get a separate $200 pool for House
Senate and presidential contests for a
maximum total of $600 for those federal
offices all right I just want to mention
that because I think it's a great idea
and I really like it I have to say in
fact I I would just make one small tweak
here just one little thing I mean the
idea of the government giving every $100
that they would then give to someone
else I like that idea the small
adjustment I would make is in in my
version of the plan everybody would give
me $600 and so we called Matt Walsh
dollars there they'd be real dollars of
course so I can go out and spend them
but but I earmarked for me and yeah I
mean that's that's the plan so that's my
suggestion I'm just throwing that out
there
you could something to think about all
right let's go to emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from Georgia says Matt
thank you for your insightful analysis
of the causes of the Civil War and
racism and context of the generation as
you were explaining how it was once
commonly accepted to be discriminatory
to people who don't look like you but
now that idea has been eradicated from
our society I couldn't help but think or
actually couldn't help screaming into my
phone that we still are far from healed
in this area as abortion is still legal
in many countries I know you understand
the similarities there and I think it
should be pointed out that in future
generations people who are pro-abortion
today will someday be thought I have a
thought of as
berrak scumbags you are absolutely 100%
correct won't surprise you that I agree
with you there and as we've been talking
about these kind of moral blind spots
that cultures have and that many calls
him maybe all cultures have had
throughout history well this is ours
this is our blind spot and I agree that
in who knows 50 years 100 years 150
years some day if the world doesn't end
before that someday people will look
back on abortion the way they look at
slavery and they're gonna see all these
things because as I have detailed in the
past the arguments for slavery are
pretty much identical to the arguments
for abortion and the reason is that it
seems like in every time in history in
in every civilization there have been
people trying to claim that some other
group of people are not people and the
people who make that argument always use
the same argument there's always the
same arguments repackaged reheated over
and over and over again and yet they can
never see they can't see that they're
doing exactly that while they are using
the argument that people in pass made
even as they condemned those people in
the past for making those arguments it's
just it's remarkable that people can be
so blind this is from Andy says I I
found myself in a predicament the
company I work for has decided to
sponsor the Pride Parade in Salt Lake
City frankly I don't know what to think
about this on one hand they aren't
actually hurting me on the other they
are disturbing the distributing rainbow
Ally badges and literally everywhere I
go I encounter a rainbow flag and
listing me to volunteer for the Pride
Parade
honestly I'm all for tolerance inclusion
and diversity of thought the problem for
me is that this feels like it goes
beyond these things into a celebration
of something a large portion of your
employee base tolerates and includes
but things celebrating is sinful I asked
HR if they knew they were alienating a
significant portion of the company they
told me that if I wanted to discuss this
I would have to schedule a meeting with
the company's directors should I
schedule the meeting or is this simply
self sabotage with nothing to gain
on another note I'm surprised Wild
Turkey rare breed is amazing and wasn't
on your bourbon recommendation list yeah
that's a tough situation Andy I don't
think I'm in a position to tell you what
to do you're gonna have a much better
feel for it than I do I will say this if
you assess that there is zero chance
that you're meeting with them would
change their mind yet a significant
chance that it will hurt your career
then no I don't think you're morally
obligated to go and jump on a grenade
with no hope of it doing anything but
blowing you to smithereens
right we aren't required to go out of
our way to martyr ourselves we're not
required to do that especially if we
have a family to support and it's ok to
take that into consideration you have to
take that into consideration that's your
job if you do have a family and even if
you don't you got to support yourself so
I would exercise caution and prudence
and I would take the path that seems
wisest and best for your family that's
just my thought but if if there's a
particular moral stand that it has has
no chance in that context of resulting
in any actual change but could
significantly hurt you for taking it
then no I don't think you need to take
it which isn't the same thing as now if
you if you were if they came to you and
said we need you to go to the Pride
Parade and take part in it and
volunteers I mean well that's different
now you're in a position where you have
to say no even if it means you get fired
right that's that anyone in that
position that's we would be required but
there's a difference between that and
just kind of remaining silently opposed
and sometimes silence is ok so it's not
like it's always cowardly
and I get questions like this all the
time with people saying with people with
these kinds of in these kinds of
situations and it's always the same
thing like you don't you don't have to
go around shout in your opinion all the
time basically begging to get fired I
think you got to kind of choose your
spots all right this is from Lee says
Matt if you were stranded on an island
with a group of people and there was
nothing to eat and someone died and you
were starving
would you eat the dead person that is a
good question
of course this this has actually
happened before there was a famous cases
there was a famous case of the rugby
team in the thing it was a 1970s that
they went down in the Andes in a plane
and they were stranded they ended up
eating the dead to survive so there are
two separate questions here it seems one
is what would I do
and then the other is what's the right
thing to do and those are not
necessarily the same question because as
for what I would do well you know you
don't know what you would do in a
desperate situation where you're
starving to death and your your survival
is on the line and death is imminent and
all that you just you don't know how you
would respond so that's a different
question from objectively what's the
right thing to do how should we react in
that situation as for that obviously
assuming that everyone agrees that it's
wrong to kill someone in order to eat
them I think we can all agree on that
but dealing with for instance the plane
crash in the Andes and people some
people survived some died and the others
were starving to death is it okay to eat
the dead in that case it's weird because
my my the sural reaction morally is to
say no it's not okay even if they're
already dead
even if you'll die if you don't seems
like it's not morally okay but then in
trying to come up with arguments to
justify my visceral moral reaction I
really can't think of any good arguments
my argument is basically it's gross but
that's not an argument right it's a
reflex
not an argument
I guess the serious argument against it
is that it's that it's the desecration
of a corpse and it's wrong to desecrate
of course but but if the intent is not
to desecrate but to survive then are we
really saying that someone has a
responsibility to die for the sake of
respecting the body of someone who's
already dead is it better to have two
dead bodies than one dead body and
another living by using the dead body I
guess it's hard to say that it's better
for a person to die than to survive by
eating the dead and besides as I think
about it is it really that much
different from say using a dead person's
heart or kidney or liver or lungs or
whatever for survival in an organ
transplant if it's desecration of the
Dead to use a body for sustenance
wouldn't it be desecration to carve
their heart out of there
you know chest cavity and put it into
another person so I can't think of a
good argument that rules out eating the
dead in a desperate situation but allows
for organ transplants it seems like very
similar sorts of things where you are I
mean to put it crudely you're harvesting
the dead for the sake of the living
seems very similar so I suppose my
answer is my answer is is although my
instinct is no it's not right I think
intellectually upon further reflection
in a desperate situation when death is
the only alternative it would be okay it
seems to eat the dead so Bon Appetit
sorry that was an appropriate way to
finish that discussion let's see this is
from Lindsey says Matt I just wanted to
tell you that although you aren't
although you aren't as ready for
primetime as some of the other
personalities on The Daily wire I think
you're by far the most interesting
person on the site now that that felt
like a backhanded compliment Lindsey I
or maybe just a backhand straight up
because in here's the thing interesting
means bad with women I know that I've
learned I've learned a few things about
women in my life just a few and one of
them is that interesting is bad and I've
learned that for my wife like I remember
a few years ago on Christmas I got her a
it was like a bracelet that I thought
was a nice bracelet I don't know but she
didn't seem that enthused by it so I
said oh do you like it and she said yeah
yeah it's it's it's it's interesting and
I said okay I dropped the ball on that
one I did I know that I did because
interesting is not now interesting from
me
is good from a mate when a man says
interesting it means oh that's
interesting I'm interested in it it's a
good thing but with women it's not and
so that's another way of saying how dare
you insult me thanks for the email
though alright finally from Bryan's as
dear mr. powerful just and supreme
glorious bearded incredibly intelligent
future king and overlord of the known
universe Matt Walsh finally someone
addresses me the way that I need to be
addressed that is my correct pronoun by
the way I have been a longtime listener
and reader of your work I have been
following you since the blaze and I
think I've heard every one of your
podcasts I am a current law student with
an undergraduate degree in etymology
entomology through which I took a
beekeeping class I think it's very cool
and I'm a little jealous of you for
having a bee hive I want to clear some
inaccuracies that you said on episode
246 about bees but you just said that
I'm future king and overlord of the
known universe now you're going to clear
up inaccuracies seems like a little bit
of an inconsistency there bees are more
radical feminists than you think males
do no work their only purpose is to mate
with queen bees they take no part in
cleaning the hive or producing the honey
they are completely helpless and rely on
their sisters for everything because as
feminists say if you want something done
right let a women do it males and Queens
are produced during late winter so by
spring they're mature and can go on
mating flights if the males do not mate
they are evicted vik today they're
sisters in the fall before winter comes
they are removed from the hive if they
are to try to re-enter and they
eventually starve to death
they're completely helpless and useless
some tips to help you make sure to have
Italy lookout I won't go into the
beekeeping tips because that's a little
bit too niche but but ya know III agree
this is one thing I've talked about them
I've noticed as a beekeeper as a new
beekeeper that it is a very feminist
anti male environment among pees so but
I mean they treat each other pretty
harsh I was out at the high of a couple
days ago and I noticed there's this one
there's a female bee trying to you know
she's coming back from a flight looking
for flowers or whatever she was doing
and she tried to come back in and she
and the other bees wouldn't let her in
they actually basically body-slammed
throw onto the ground and then she you
know just waddled away she wasn't
allowed to come back and so there are
andum Lea decide to evict I don't know
if they do it by lottery or something I
don't know how they decide but they'll
randomly decide well you know look women
can be a little bit they can turning on
each other kind of kwibi new female
friendships can be a little bit finicky
and and and volatile at times and so I
guess there was some drama in hive and
this girl was on the outs and so they
sent her out and anyway she died but
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed
I'm Michael Noel's host of the Michael
Noel's show students at Hofstra
University are demanding the school tear
down a statue of Thomas Jefferson
meanwhile in Northern California public
school district wants to remove a mural
of George Washington we will analyze the
end of history check it out at daily
wire.com